how would you feel if your daughter
sister or mother were raped on a train
over the course of 27 stops for 40
minutes while other trained passengers
and there were many picked up their
phones not to call the police not to
call 9-1-1 but to videotape the act
being perpetrated in front of them
no one interfered no one yells stop no
one tried to end the horror being
inflicted upon this innocent helpless
woman instead they chose to take out
their phones and videotape the maddening
violence occurring before them so far
none have volunteered those videos to
police
what to conclude
it was for entertainment purposes
we used to say if you see something say
something today
it's see something say nothing
folks not only is this a reflection of
how our society is disintegrated it is a
reflection of the dehumanization of
crime victims of a culture that has no
feeling for the victim of crime
the this can never happen to me attitude
is adopted so people feel they are
immune and so they only see the acts
through the lens of entertainment
but it gets worse
the rapist had been ordered deported but
an appellate immigration judge protected
him in spite of his convictions for
drugs and sex abuse
in the end a woman was forced to suffer
because a judge determined the criminal
twice convicted deserved to live in
america and by the way there are no good
samaritan laws in the united states that
require that anyone intervene in a
situation like this
lawlessness in this country is worse
than ever
what's different however is a sense of
permission the criminals have that
they're allowed to vent to steal to loot
after all businesses have insurance
so we let them steal with no consequence
no arrest no conviction no jail time
we'll let them burn down neighborhoods
and businesses because they want social
justice as if the destruction of
property and lives brings them anything
it only hurts victims
murders are spiked
in major democrat-run cities across this
country
up in cities like portland 57 percent
austin 71
los angeles 65
las vegas 71
children going to buy candy are shot at
a one-year-old sitting in a stroller
shot and killed
children in their own homes in their own
beds a place that they have a right to
be
are shot and killed by criminals who
don't deserve to breed the same air that
we do
and a four-year-old girl shot on her way
to a toy store in times square
in cities across america police are not
only being handcuffed they're being
defunded demoralized and told to stand
down ordered not to arrest and if they
do
the swinging door of no bail lets the
criminal out to reoffend
prosecutors funded by george soros are
all over this country they do not take
the mantle of victims they spend their
time refusing to prosecute crime and
then release criminals from prison
bail reform is nothing but a euphemism
for letting the criminals out to
reoffend to reoffend to steal to assault
and yes to kill again
and even the title
gives the criminal top billing it's the
criminal justice system when it should
be the victim justice system the victim
the one who never chose to be a part of
the system in the first place
and parents seeking to protect their
children are impotent against a
federation of teachers who seek to
protect themselves and empower
themselves and when they finally show up
to teach our children they teach them to
become little marxist activists they're
so woke they seek to allow students to
determine their sex based on how they
feel that day which is how
a 15 year old boy in loudoun county
wearing a skirt was able to rape and
forcibly sodomize an innocent ninth
grade girl in the girl's bathroom at
school
and when that victim's girl dad tried to
voice his opinion at the school board
meeting on the issue of allowing
transgender
students into the students bathrooms he
was arrested called a domestic terrorist
a phrase that was then taken up by the
national association of school boards
then made into a poster board that then
provided the radical attorney general
garland with the basis he used to deploy
national law enforcement the fbi against
parents in the united states of america
and let's not forget the border we don't
screen them we don't vet them who among
them is a criminal who among them is a
gang member like notorious ms-13 who's a
pedophile who's a sex offender who
thinks they're entitled to beat their
wives i want to know who has an alcohol
problem who has a drug problem who likes
to drive drunk and who has no problem
hauling drugs for the cartel
we americans are left to experience this
ourselves because the biden
administration lies and says the border
is closed the border's closed
1.7 million have entered since january
and countless more haven't even been
counted
have you had enough
are you disgusted yet
i'll tell you it just got worse in new
york city with a leftist radical mayor
offering a thousand dollars a month to
criminals to not commit a crime
san francisco
it's is not prosecuting any crime under
950 dollars forcing scores of walgreens
stores drugstores to close
and now
they're stealing from cars where they
smash windows knowing they'll never be
arrested so they can keep doing it again
and again
and then atlanta two days ago
crime witnesses again
videotape instead of calling 9-1-1 where
a homicide occurs
we are the greatest nation on earth
we are quickly becoming like a third
world nation and we can thank the
democrats we can thank joe biden and we
can thank the leftist mayors and
governors for allowing crime to go
unpunished
we cannot survive as a nation much
longer with this kind of assault on our
citizens
there is only one answer to the historic
increase in crime and the catastrophic
breakdown of morals in our society that
leads to people not caring about one
another
democrats who support a leftist marxist
socialist agenda the ones who don't care
about us
have to be thrown out of
office it's time to take crime
personally it's time to get angry about
crime if we don't
we will prove abraham lincoln right when
he said america will never be conquered
by a foreign power but if we are to die
we die by suicide alone hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else